In Our world view,
excellence equals design times,
culture.
So half the battle is getting the design
of the organization right.
And um,
these are things like,
you know,
choosing very strategically where to
excel and we're to underperform and that
that's a design function and you have to
make sure that the business model works
and then it can scale.
And then it's systematically setting
people up to perform.
The other half is,
is culture.
And you know,
one of the reasons that culture matters
so much in service organizations is that
we need our employees to,
um,
every day on the front lines make
decisions that are,
that end up defining the customer
experience in managing those employees.
The handbook only gets you so far,
you know,
you,
and part of that is because customers
are wildly,
wonderfully unpredictable.
You don't know on the front lines and
the service organization,
what's going to happen moment to moment
and culture tells you what to do where,
um,
when there isn't a policy or precedent.
And so it's a,
it's a hugely important asset in service
organizations.
So Southwest Airlines,
the reason we love it is that it's an,
it's in perhaps the worst industry of
all time.
So the industry has essentially
destroyed more value than it's created
since its inception.
And then there's southwest who's
profitable every year,
every year for one decade,
every year for another decade,
every year for another decade.
They do it by this beautiful elegance of
focus.
They are very comfortable saying,
we do this,
we don't do that.
Which means they have great strategy and
they're very great at delivering
excellence because they say,
we'll do these things well,
turnaround time,
being on time.
We'll do these things badly.
Go on board of Southwest Airlines flight
and ask someone for a full meal.
They have no shame,
no apology.
They might mock you a little bit in
their reply.
They understand what they're optimized
to be great at.
They understand what they have to give
up in order to deliver on that.
And they understand it from the top of
the organization all the way down to the
bottom.
One of the things that southwest does in
a training experience is,
um,
they get everyone,
all the new recruits in a room,
and they have everyone stand up and
share their most embarrassing moment.
So people in the moment think this is
pretty hardcore.
I mean,
they're,
they're testing us for poise and our
ability to communicate in a stressful
situation.
And it turns out southwest isn't looking
at the speaker.
They're looking at everyone else and
they're looking for signs of empathy.
And so when they see signs of empathy in
that crowd,
those are the people that they ended up
hiring.
So it's,
you know,
it's a great example of a distinct
clarity on the values that are important
to them and figuring out how to find
them,
uh,
in the hiring.
Yeah.
Process excellence is designed times
culture.
You have to get the design right and you
have to get the culture right.
Great design.
Bad Culture won't work.
Great culture,
bad design won't work.
We need both.
In southwest is just a magnificent
illustration of both.
Okay.